although in many cases it's a dark shade of
gray.
And along those lines today, we have to talk
about the talking points that are spreading
about undemocratically stealing the nomination
from Bernie Sanders compared to actually building
consensus within the democratic party.
Now, as you all know, by now, there's no doubt
that the democratic establishment does not
want Bernie Sanders to be the democratic presidential
nominee, just like was the case in 2016.
Now you don't have to support Bernie Sanders,
uh, to in order to, uh, believe that you would
have to be quite naive at this point.
To deny that, you know, everything from the
MSNBC coverage and the aftermath of Bernie's
win in Nevada to the DNC considering re allowing
the super delegates to vote on round one at
the convention.
All of this stuff is evidence that the democratic
establishment doesn't want Bernie to be the
nominee.
Okay.
Now, there are a couple of ways that Bernie
could end up with more pledge delegates than
anybody else, but not end up with the nomination.
Not all of those scenarios are equally problematic
in the context of how nominations are decided.
Now, listen, I know there are people who are
going to see this video and they're going
to dislike it and say, David's advocating
for this, that I'm not doing anything other
than informing my audience about how this
works and allowing people to have the information
to decide for themselves when something is
or is not undemocratic.
Now this is really important because like
80% of the commentaries I'm seeing from the
left about how Bernie may have the domination
denied are accurate, 80% are accurate.
There's 20% that are missing the Mark and
what I want to do is distinguish between the
two scenarios that are the most likely so
that we can all be on the same page.
If you don't like that, if you want to punish
me and you want to dislike this video on YouTube
or write me a mean letter, go ahead, but I'm
going to do the show the way I think the show
should be done and informing people about
this is really important.
So let's look first at the cartoonish obvious
and disgusting way that Bernie could have
more delegates than anybody else and end up
not being the nominee.
If Bernie Sanders gets a plurality of pledged
delegates in the primaries and then there's
a first round of voting at the DNC and nobody
gets to 50% plus one delegates, then they
do a second round of voting with super delegates
and Bernie could lose.
This would not be Bernie losing because there
was consensus built between the delegates
of different candidates.
This would simply be a completely undemocratic
process, a mirroring of the 2016 scenario
except with super delegates voting in the
second round instead of in the first, it would
be completely shameful.
I am against the inclusion and use of superdelegates
all altogether.
It's undemocratic.
It's an establishment centrist perversion
of what should be a democratic process.
There is also another scenario that could
deny Bernie Sanders the nomination and we
may not like the outcome, but it does reflect
a sort of consensus building that is often
a requirement of the political system working
correctly.
Even if we don't like the outcome, I will
lay it out for you.
Imagine that Bernie Sanders has a plurality
of the delegates but not a majority, which
seems quite likely at this point.
Although things could shift and Bernie could
end up with a majority.
Let's imagine Bernie has 35% of the delegates
heading into the convention.
It is completely conceivable that in advance
of that first vote at the DNC, super delegates
aren't involved.
Three Centrus candidates might combine their
delegates and get to 50% plus one.
It would be a negotiation between the candidates
and their supporters.
Imagine, let's make it really specific.
Imagine that going into the convention now
we'll use other numbers.
Bernie has.
Bernie has 28% of the delegates.
Pete boot edge edge has 21% and Joe Biden
has 16% and AB Klobuchar has 14% I believe
that when you vote for a candidate in the
primary, you are voting for their decision
making ability in total.
And if you vote Amy and she decides that the
convention, my policies are more likely to
be enacted by Biden than by Bernie.
And she says, Hey, Amy delegates go and vote
for Biden.
And if the Buddha judge people do the same
thing, they could negotiate for all of those
delegates to support Joe Biden and Biden would
get 50% plus one Bernie had more delegates
than any one other candidate, but of course
most of the delegates were for other candidates.
And you could see that negotiation take place.
It's not super delegates coming in from above
and undemocratically handing the nomination
to someone.
Now, if you don't like that, you can argue
there should be no such negotiations possible
in advance of that first round of voting.
But the problem is in a field where imagine
you have 15 or 18 candidates, the candidate
with a plurality might only have nine 10 11
12% of the vote.
In that case, do we want a system that says
even with 11% of the vote, if it's a plurality,
that candidate must be the nominee when 89%
voted for somebody else, it doesn't sound
completely right to me, even if it leads to
an outcome that is not the one I want.
So now let me be absolutely crystal clear.
I'm voting for Bernie Sanders in the primary.
I believe super delegates should not decide
the nomination, but we need to dis-aggregate
the two scenarios.
Imagine it going a different way.
Imagine Bernie gets his 37% of the delegates.
Okay?
Going into the convention and Elizabeth Warren
has 14% we know if Bernie doesn't get that
first ballot nomination on the second round,
super delegates give it to somebody else.
Elizabeth Warren could direct her delegates.
Her 14% to vote for Bernie.
37 plus 14 is 51 and that gets Bernie to the
nomination on the first round.
It's a progressive consensus building movement.
It's not practically speaking different than
the delegates of two, three or four centrists
candidate.
It's doing the same thing.
We may not like the system, in which case
we should lobby for it to be changed, but
that scenario is not the authoritarian undemocratic
nightmare of superdelegates coming in and
simply saying, nothing does.
No negotiations and no consensus building.
The superdelegates just vote for Biden or
for Buddha judge or whatever.
Let's maintain credibility and consistency.
Let's acknowledge that these are two different
scenarios and let's work to ensure that working
within that, no super delegates.
The first process there that I mentioned is
the undemocratic superdelegate one.
We're against that.
But let's work knowing that the second scenario
could happen to build consensus and to do
what needs to be done for the candidate.
We want to be the nominee.
If you think that this is a distinction without
a difference, I disagree with you and I want
to hear
from you.
Tell me what's wrong with
my analysis.